It's 1 10,
but he eliminated Mélenchon in the presidential election.
2 is 1 10,
but he participated
to thedeux-mille-vingt-trois riots in France.
0 is 1 10,
but he is vegan.
Well,
he's getting rid of a lot of things.
Uh.
4 is 1 10,
but it's propotine.
Propotine.
2 is a clue,
but he spends two hours a day on TikTok.
That's too much,
that's too much.
I think it dumbed down a bit.
Uh,
I say that.
And at the same time,
we will surely be broadcast on TikTok.
But look 1 little,
but not too much,
go to the end of the video,
but then you cut
so, uh 6 come on,
it's a clue,
but he's watching his news
Antice,
it is clue,
but it is mediaparte.
I like mediaparte,
uh.
They have 1 ideological bias,
they are of the extreme left,
they assume it.
Uh 5 is 1-10,
but he throws his cigarette butts on the floor.
3 is 1 10,
but he drives an SUV.
4 is 1 10,
but it is for flexitis.
but he will not vote in the European elections.
4 you have to go and vote.
There are reasons not to vote.
I understand many people
who are disgusted by politics,
but you have to go and vote
to change things from the inside.